foreign
[Music]
hey guys and uh it's me and I'm gonna be
in Vegas soon I I just had a Sunday show
July 23rd so go to chrisley.com
Charlotte North Carolina Knoxville
Tennessee Little Rock Arkansas Nashville
Tennessee Calgary Edmonton Ottawa
Montreal
Pittsburgh Cleveland Detroit uh some of
those are sold out but uh other ones are
not so go check it out uh and without
further ado since I got all that out of
the way right there early go to
chrisley.com and get tickerinos
um let's start the new episode of
congratulations
[Music]
dude guess what I did today first of all
I put a
video up on Instagram that when
dummy viral I
I'm so sorry
uh it was about how I didn't mean to
match and I matched and I absolutely
look ridiculous anyway and my drip was
just fantastic I slipping and falling
all over the place right
and uh
I did it again
I didn't mean to but I did it again
today I wore pink shorts with the
tie-dyed socks that say life rips on
them where you can get them at
chrisley.com those socks are absolutely
ill and pink and white shoes and a white
shirt Whoopsie Daisy yeah
yeah I did do it yeah yeah
I did it
um so Whoopsie Daisy the drip was
absolutely Sensational the drip was
absolutely where is it where is it
sensation
um so yeah
um I did that that was me that did that
that was me that did that
so uh we're having a good time here over
at the congratulations podcast studio uh
check out congratulations check out
Lifeline make sure you're subscribed and
like the video make sure you subscribe
to super good
um for videos right got the crystalia
channel 2 that we put up there and it's
got some stand up on it actually right
now that I just uploaded and the last
Pueblo Colorado uh some stand up from
there and then also the tour report
um but yeah dude and uh let's talk about
the elephant in the Rune room not roon
let's talk about the elephant in the
room I'm tan
as if it couldn't get better dude the
Teardrops are coming in right above the
knees Johnny hips cry making a
Rising Like a Phoenix because dude I do
squats but dude Whoopsie Daisy he's also
darker than usual whoops
oh no dude he's giving Sheriff toaster a
run for his money because he's almost
brown
um yeah
but he doesn't have like Mommy dude uh
I got bleep that out maybe because it's
three minutes in we can't say that we're
good
dude so you know I'm
imagine me imagine me just getting out
the pool dude glistening and all that
[__] oh my God is the sun going down
imagine me just rising out of the pool
like that just chest all nice just
pushing out right
just imagine that glistening in the
moonlight just oh just under the
right
just
so that's you know just imagine it right
the cover of a romance novel I wanna I
know dude if I was on the cover of a
romance novel could you imagine not even
all that fit just kind of like is it a
dad bod or not
you know that's what they should do
about
um
dad about um romance novels they should
put guys that are like not Dad bods but
it's like I mean it's kind of good I
guess his body I don't know
kind of not the guy I would pick for the
cover
like not Fabio I wonder what what that
would do to sales but
anyway I did George janko's podcast uh
I don't know I I I did it the other day
it's out you can go check that out we
had a really nice conversation
um it was fun and funny love him and his
girlfriend they're so sweet they both
were sitting in on the podcast and uh
you can go check that out over at the
George Janko Channel I don't know man
but I'm tan so whoops and my wife
doesn't even appreciate it told her I
was tanned didn't appreciate it dude I
said I'm 10 baby I woke up first thing I
said in the morning I said baby you
realize how 10 I am and she goes I've
been up for five hours already so
whatever that's not that's mostly
Billy's fault that's not my fault that's
William's fault so Whoopsie Daisy there
we go right
uh he's rolling over he's doing all
sorts of stuff you know I'm a family man
man I'm a family man
uh love my family
and uh that's about that
I don't know about the friggin um
what's the news threads is the news
right threads is out there
uh everyone who got an Instagram could
just sign up for Threads
they did it through Instagram uh
Zuckerberg
goes like this oh yeah Elon all right
well what about this because Twitter was
tanking
um I don't know what Twitter you know
Twitter's kind of I like you know look
the good thing about Twitter is they
don't censor anything right is that a
good thing or a bad thing I don't know I
mean you can't make death threats but
also
the good thing about it is YouTube will
flag a lot of stuff even if it's comedy
right even if they're joking as we've
seen with Roseanne Barr which he said on
this past weekend the podcast with Theo
and um
and then they just put it on Twitter and
it's on Twitter and Elon Musk tweeted it
out and said comedy's legal here on this
platform and that's good because
comedy's comedy
um and truly what obviously Theo and
Roseanne Barr are doing it's comedy it's
just straight up comedy it's not not
there's they're both comedians they're
on a comedy podcast to flag any of that
is to me it's just crazy people talk
about freedom of free speech of course
it's not free speech it's a business
YouTube can do whatever they want I get
it and Twitter it's nice that Elon is
like [__] it this is how we're doing it
comedy's comedy but Twitter's been kind
of a dumpster fire with the check mark
stuff and then they were having people
pay for check marks and then they were
having people not like pay for them and
then like
something about how they like like took
it away or something and then they made
another one and you could have a
different kind of Checkmate I don't know
what the hell it was but the fact that I
don't even know what's going on and I
you know I'm not active on Twitter but
the fact that I even know what's going
on I don't even know what's going on is
crazy because Twitter used to be the
place for information and now there's
just so much crazy [__] out there
everyone's just pieces of [__] but
Mark Zuckerberg goes like this yo
watch this and then he goes like this
hey guys not oh Twitter nice but check
this out threads
[Music]
and he made threads
um and
you know
now it's a Twitter that Instagram dude
genius tying it into it into Instagram
huh Instagram wow how many 85 years old
genius tying it into Instagram everyone
already got the built-in [__]
right I follow Ben Baller on Instagram I
I make a thread go to threads I'm
already following Ben Baller on threads
okay
I don't have to redo everything huh
I could also post threads to my stories
okay
driving traffic my babies
am I on the 405 because I'm driving
traffic
that dice Americano with five ice cubes
in it is specific but that's how he does
it he knows what he likes
um so anyway who knows what kind of a
you know basically all apps are going to
be a dumpster fire sooner or later
because everything turns into the same
thing everything
the same thing do you realize that
everything turns into the same thing
they all rip each other off that's what
happens everyone just rips each other
off [__] Burger King comes out with
the Whopper big uh McDonald's comes out
the big map Wendy's comes out with
whatever the [__] Wendy's has you know
the [__] Burger you know whatever it is
right the most meat oh who's that one we
have the beef done
is that Arby's
Ving Rams right
we have the beef stunts
think of my comedy suffering because I
have a two kids now like that Calvin
would just think that what I just did is
a riot
we have the beef or does it say we are
the beef who knows
we have the beef Dong Dong Dong Dong
Arby's sandwich so much beef patty it's
[__] ridiculous dude I could do
Arby's commercials Orbeez two buns
around some meat and all that stuff in
it crazy Arby's we have the beef stunts
Orbeez the new Orbeez mustache Burger
it's got hair in it
so
I don't even know what I was talking
about but uh yeah so everything's
becoming what it is Starbucks has the
frilly ashes then what happens Starbucks
has the frilly yes
and then Coffee Bean goes today
still feel
um
but uh yeah I don't know Instagram
basically is Twitter in a way and so is
Tick Tock you just post whatever the
hell you want there on it I go to tick
tock now I go I upload I look at Tick
Tock I'm not even I don't scroll Tick
Tock I'm on Tick Tock obviously you
could look at my dummy viral videos but
I don't even look at Tick Tock because
now half the things on Tick Tock are
just [__] paragraphs people are just
like
you know
when I was 10 I walked in on my parents
doing
sex
for some reason they won't write sex or
drugs drugs
um
so everything's the same dude
and that's fine you know that's fine but
uh
that's what's up
I I uh gotta be honest I
am
they got me dude not since
not since Snakes on a Plane
did a movie did a movie trick me so much
then the Flash
remember mistakes on a plane the
marketing for that everyone was going oh
what the oh it's called Snakes on a
Plane oh my God Sam Jackson's actually
saying the thing that Sam Jackson would
say if he was on a movie where snakes
were on a plane
I'm gonna get these [__] snakes
off this [__] play he's actually
doing the thing oh my God but that
doesn't translate into here's eleven
dollars
I thought it would
but it didn't
hype is all hype
that's all it is
hype is hype
everyone was hyping the [__] out of the
flash you know and the guy
uh I can't remember his name right now
what's his name Elon McGregor what is it
ezron Miller
Elon McGregor
but I thought that movie was gonna go
Bonkers because James Gunn was like just
the best DC movie I've ever seen people
saying it's the best DC movie I've ever
seen wow I saw the DC movie best DC
movie ever seen
The Flash is now going to lose 200
million dollars dude that's what they
project and it is the biggest superhero
office superhero office box office
disaster of all time and that's crazy
dude and that's crazy let me tell you
why that's crazy because Wonder Woman
1984 exists
okay and that movie I would you know
people say they'd rather watch paint dry
I'd rather watch
the underside of my own I'd rather watch
I'd rather put one eyeball on an anus
and one eyeball right on tucked under
some nuts and just have my nose resting
on a taint for however long 1984 is
and let's not forget Pedro Pasquale is
on that too let's not forget Pedro
Pascal is in that movie that dog [__]
don't forget
1984 is dog [__] and I need itself
everyone said flash is so good and they
go yo it's so good and actually Elon
McGregor is amazing in it because he
plays two parts he's not just red
flashes yellow flash or some [__] that
they do he's also another flash he's
also a different flash he's an old one
he's a young flash Dude too many okay I
don't like the Multiverse shits have it
all be in one verse
single verse
that's it I'm crystalia I don't have
another podcast and Lifeline I'm not you
know
a buzz cut
Multiverse I'm a single verse
so that's really you know
I don't know I just uh I don't I'm not
I'm not into I'm not into that so I so I
was like okay good it's gonna do well
and that you know look the movie's gonna
do well I know people only give a [__]
about superhero movies now and people
really want to see Michael Keaton in the
cape even though he needs a cane
um
and uh I'm watching the I'm watching
this unfold and it bombs and it bombs
and it bombs 200 million dollars worth
and I'm like okay I get it they had a
bad movie I think that they actually
thought it was going to be good then
they aired it and it turns into
you know people don't give a [__] I
guess I don't know
I don't know if they'll make number two
or make number whatever three or make a
prequel or change the whole thing how
long are they gonna how long is this
superhero movies thing gonna go right I
mean they got [__] Blue Beetle coming
out it's like oh yeah I kind of remember
that one
I kind of remember that one
oh you know they're just making them up
at this point now I feel like yeah this
was a superhero that would they got a
bunch of they're writing the comic books
now and putting them online and [__] and
like in the 1930s style and then they're
like yeah that's the [__] that that
was it Mr Hat Guy this is coming out now
Mr hack guy and the Mr hack Guy
Multiverse sorry it sounded like my wife
was having a party I had to cut a little
bit and tell her to be a little bit
quieter um
but yeah I do it it's just like uh I was
shocked that that movie bombed honestly
The Flash I was really shocked and I'm
good at that [__] I always know dude I
know when a movie's gonna bomb I've been
when they tried to make that Michael B
Jordan the Michael basketball Jordan
movie with the [__] um
uh where he was a lawyer and I go no
Hollywood we're not doing that they're
not gonna we're not go I don't nobody's
gonna go see this [__] movie where
Michael B Jordan is gonna be a play
about a [__] lawyer dude if you don't
get to see Michael B Jordan's [__]
figure a little bit in the movie that's
it nobody wants to see him walk into a
[__] Brown room with a briefcase
nobody dude wants to see Michael B
Jordan in a [__] suit walk into a
brown room with a briefcase with a
handle on it nobody do it
foreign
it also still blows my [__] mind his
name is Michael Jordan dude Michael B
Jordan's name is actually Michael Jordan
that's already the most famous guy
I mean that's insane dude
it's insane that everyone just lets him
go
dude hey when he was in Hollywood people
should have been like yo there's already
a guy like this
it will be like if there was another
[__] like like a sh like dude if if
there was a chef named Hugh Jackman
people be like I'm not going there
he's Wolverine and that's it
it's it's it it's so weird dude
um
also when was Michael when the [__] was
Michael B Jordan
born
when was Michael Michael B Jordan
uh year 87.
okay so Michael Jordan that was like
right when Michael Jordan started
playing right
Jordan
NBA career
uh
uh when did he start
when does it say he started
since he was born in 1960.
start playing wow
when
oh sorry he's still somebody man they
should have known
they should have known they honestly
they should have [__] known dude
really
he was Rookie of the Year too that's
[__] that's you know what dude that
sucks I mean it worked out for him in
the end
she did it on purpose
oh my God his dad is [__] Michael a
Jordan
I mean dude are you kidding me this
kid's gonna Michael Jordan's gonna have
a kid's gonna be Michael C Jordan
Michael D Jordan 26 uh [__] what do
you call it
Cycles it's going to be Michael Z Jordan
the German hello
why I'm here to act in movies gave me my
brief kicks where is the round room
um
these [__] movies are out of control
can anything be a a really kind of a hit
anymore oh you know what I was calling
whether I was gonna call Indiana Jones
failure dude I knew it I knew it was
gonna be a failure do you know why dude
nobody gives a [__] about Indiana Jones
and I'm gonna go ahead and say it
Indiana Jones was always [__] stupid
oh [__] dude
oh he's mad dude I haven't get rid of
his mat dude Harrison Ford was a [__] he
really was this [__] dude let me tell
you something about Indiana Jones way
too much Brown in it there's never any
other colors okay it's too much Brown
and bad
acting Harrison Ford is a [__] I'm not
saying Harrison Ford is not the [__] her
support is good everyone beyond that
it's so ridiculous Indiana Jones [__]
sucks it's for kids so fine I get it but
hold on a second though it's for kids
okay so you make the [__] what is it
Indiana Jones five 90 years later the
kids they don't give a [__] who's gonna
go see a movie now they all got kids
the people my age they're not gonna go
they don't give a [__] that much you got
to make movies for kids so that's what
the Marvel shits is doing that's what DC
is doing if you're Indiana Jones living
off Nostalgia Nostalgia [__] everything
up dude
it [__] everything up I saw a post the
other day it was like oh look at the
beach in 1970 versus the beach now the
beach in 1970 everyone no one had
tattoos everyone was fit and just
soaking in sun rays no cancerous creams
putting on each other it's like yeah
dude but [__] everyone died of like
other [__]
the life expectancy is better now you're
living off Nostalgia what a nostalgic
tank
what a nostalgic take that [__]
Indiana Jones Is Gonna Do Well
I mean why don't you just big up Gregory
Peck's body and make it [__] CGI and
put it in the in the in the nobody gives
a [__] dude Indiana Jones was set to
bomb Harrison Ford's dead
well you gotta run Indiana Jones gotta
run right
I can't run
and I like Harrison Ford but dude that
was just destined to bomb
know what else is going to bomb mark my
[__] words Barbie
gonna bomb dude nobody gives a [__]
dude little girls don't give a [__]
about Barbie anymore are you kidding me
look at all the dope [__] out there
I'm if they do give a [__] they're not
gonna pay [__] 11 you know how tough
it is for people to go hey Oliver here's
left by the way we have [__] merch
out there christia.com
go to my website and [__] get that
[__]
I I'm a heated off of stuff that doesn't
really matter but it's okay dude that's
how it goes
um
it's crazy dude
Hollywood set it up like like like
I don't know people need it or something
but they don't need it
everything's so splintered
my son was on the I put my son to bed
last night
no it was two nights ago and he had new
uh jammies on that is Uncle Matt got him
and uh
their uh
skeleton
and dude I told you that what my kid
said last podcast bro the [__] that he
said man it's I don't have to I said I
don't even have to write a material
anymore my kid goes
Calvin
he says I said and let me get a picture
I want to send it to Uncle Matt
because she got to the PJs and it goes
like this takes a picture okay
flash goes off because it was dark in
his room and my son goes like this
watch and learn and just Dives head
first into his mattress
like
where the [__] did he learn to watch and
learn
watch this all day long he goes watch
and learn like I'm I don't want to learn
that number one and then I actually did
try it because like I want to be like a
youthful dad
and that hurts and he's like Dad how
come you're not falling and I'm like
buddy
my body is 200 something pounds right
I'm beefy dude did you forget
did you forget I do deadlifts did you
forget
um
I don't know
this shit's out of control dude did you
see about this this is crazy right now
um
the the thing about the uh
let me just pull it up
this was on a bunch of different see now
though this is crazy the mainstream
media won't report on this the only
people that report on this is Daily Mail
which is
you know but like no app actual media
would
this is how shitty the media is
so
this is this whole trans thing they keep
moving the goal post
cancer charity has been accused of
dehumanizing women after advising Medics
to refer
to the vagina
as a bonus hole
how could you make the actual word
vagina less sexy
they had to change the like people say
like
you know you know we don't say the bad
words on here but p-u-s-s-y and you know
they go like this oh God yeah that's so
it's a beautiful fried butterfly or oh
my God that's a great Hatchet one
whatever
but like
a bonus hole
and that they want to
use a cancer charity I mean dude they
want to say bonus hole to avoid upset
upsetting transgender men
cervical cancer trust features a
glossary on its website detailing the
correct language that Healthcare
professionals should you should use see
this is the thing when you try to make
people talk about talk the way you want
them to
um the correct language that Healthcare
professors should use when dealing with
trans men women who identify as men so
that would be a bonus hole for them and
not a vagina wow dude hey so wait okay
so this is
trans men to women who identify as men
just happen to have oh that's not a
vagina because I'm a man that's a bonus
hole ah it's a vagina well but it's a
bonus because I don't use it but okay so
a bonus for what I just get to have it
just like a little bonus there
women's rights campaigners last week
There's a thing about they keep moving
the goal post right
and look I don't look at this hat the
fact is women have vaginas it's
appalling that anyone would think
reality reality is offensive you think
it's offensive then that's your problem
they're just losing people left and
right I don't you know look if you were
to ask me what do I think uh uh do I
think a man is born a man and a woman's
born a woman uh if they have a man has a
penis and a woman has a vagina I would
say yes okay now I don't look I'm an I'm
a comedian I'm not a [__] scientist I
don't know biology I could be the
biggest idiot in the world in that
respect Maybe I'm Wrong I have no
[__] idea it's just what I think okay
but the problem is the fact that people
think because of me thinking that that
not only should I be shamed into
thinking the other way but I'm creating
and perpetuating violence
now guess what I'm thinking it more
because that's not a discussion you need
to have a dialogue about it if you don't
then you're not going to get anybody
over on your side and then keep moving
the goal post keep moving the goal post
keep moving the goal post until a vagina
is a Glo is a glorial is a
it's actually it's glorious but is a
[__] bonus hole
you know it's a bonus hole my [__] I
have to [__] out of that sucks you think
I want to be [__] no but gotta so
that's a bonus for me
if as a matter of fact if I had any
other hole on me any other hole I would
be like I hope that's not a vagina
that would be where my mind goes right
too not up extra hole dude it's just
crazy so you know if you want to say
that that's conservative that's
conservative I don't give a [__]
I mean they got they got they got a uh
uh I was just reading the other day this
uh transgender woman won a competition
um in like
some country beauty pageant for women
[Laughter]
and like it's funny enough for the
sports stuff to happen like what you
know what I mean like how how trans
women will beat the [__] at any other
women in sports because they're actually
secretly men but dude the [__] it's
so funny and Beauty passions pageants
because those women in beauty pageants
are super like still down with oh yeah
women are beautiful and I'm beautiful
and I don't give a [__] about what like
people say about like stop stop shaming
me because I want to be like a pin-up
girl or whatever the [__] you know or be
beautiful in my gown like women can be
pretty and and and that's cool too you
know not everyone has to be a [__]
man and uh and I don't mean that in a
trans way I just mean that women
you know it's like when men and women
are different and women who do women who
do pageants are cool with being
different right and so the fact so they
super believe in that [__] so the fact
that a trans woman won that now it you
see all the other women that are just
like yay and they're just in their head
it's just like
that
just [__] just bombs going off and
everything we've everything the [__]
look how far we came we've came we got
to [__] vote we got to do all this
[__] we got to have all the jobs we
could wear whatever we want and now a
thought all for what so a [__] man
can win this
I'm not saying that's what I'm thinking
but that's what they're thinking it's
100 but that's worth thinking and they
also it's what I'm thinking
but it's just so [__] silly dude you
can't keep progressing you just can't
you have to stop at some point otherwise
the progression goes to regression
you can it's like that movie [__]
family man with Nicholas Cage or
whatever the hell it's called it was
good it was probably good and they just
kept rewriting it
you know it's like stop rewriting the
[__] [__] dude
stop progressing it's fine we did it
and now you got Charlie's Angels [__]
it sucks donkey balls dude because
there's 150 writers on it
you already figured it out dude it's
like the iPhone what was the best iPhone
now it's just like they have to keep
changing they have to keep changing so
everyone's like oh dude yeah they
they're evolving well it was already the
best dude they changed dumb [__] on
there now
because they have to otherwise you think
they're not evolving isn't that crazy
they got to make little changes
otherwise you think it sucks after a
while
it's our fault it's our faults
it is what it is dude
when I'm having sex with my wife next
I'm gonna say oh my God your bonus hole
is amazing
sweetheart and then they just say what
and I'll say did you read the article
from Daily Mail all while having sex
what are you talking about a cancer
research group is saying that they
should call it a bonus hole instead of a
vagina oh yeah because of how um uh yeah
because of how transgender it off a
vagina offends transgender mental oh
yeah because trans because transgender
men don't you know they don't have
I mean they they don't want to stink
they have a vagina even though they were
born women oh so they call it a bonus
hole
it feels so good
what
[Laughter]
awesome bonus haul
I gotta go to I can't wait to get to
Vegas I'll tell you what I'm so excited
to get to Vegas I got Vegas shows in
Vegas soon I can't wait to go to Vegas
go to chrisley.com for the tickets but I
can't wait to go to Vegas because I want
to see this [__] sphere
that they have the I don't know what
it's called it's like a 15 000 seat
uh Arena it's called the sphere so I got
it right pretty much hit the nail on the
head and it it has so many LCD screens
it can be an eyeball it could be the
Moon it could be a soccer ball
basketball it could be a bunch of
different swirly things I mean it could
be so many different things
and this thing is so big and it's about
time Vegas has some [__] like this I'm
talking about Bonkers [__] because
everyone was talking about how Vegas was
the [__] Vegas was the [__] and then in
the 90s it stopped kind of being the
[__] because you know everyone was dying
in hotel rooms we were jumping off you
know jumping off the [__]
you know killing themselves and jumping
you can jump off every building in Vegas
except for the the uh the what was the
what's the one the Excalibur what's the
none of the Excalibur
Luxor because you just jump off at the
top and you slide all the way down
because it's a [__] pyramid you know
[__] this I lost Millions oh oh well
actually you know
that was awesome dude they should charge
people for that ride the ride the Luxor
but anyway
um
it's about time dude Vegas is back dude
this big ass sphere I'm gonna go look at
it man you think I won't look at it I'll
look at it dude and I'm not talking
about from the plane I'm not talking
about driving by I'm talking about I'm
gonna go to look at it dude I'm gonna
stand there through all the rotations
and I'm gonna look at it
it's gonna be hard as [__] but I'm still
gonna do that I'm gonna do it at night
because it'll be nice at night but I
will tell you
dude imagine how many [__] accidents
that's gonna cost like straight up
like oh look it's a it looks like the
Earth boom your last words are gonna be
like a big soccer ball
that could be your last words
what's that oh what's it becoming that's
gonna be the most
spoken last words in Vegas
that Vegas fear looks [__] crazy
they really but what happens when one or
two of those [__] screens go out you
gotta fix it immediately do it it's
gonna look so bad if it's not all there
I'm already pissed about I'm pissed
they shouldn't have done it you know
what now come to think of it that's
still going to be something in 10 years
that they're gonna be like why'd they do
this [__] it's all [__] breaking down
I know they got other [__] better than
it this is just the first version of it
dude I don't like it never mind I'm not
gonna see it
okay
um
I saw this documentary on uh I think it
was Hulu Ashley Madison documentary
bro you guys know about Ashley Madison
I didn't know about I I didn't know
about astronauts I did not know about
this series on Hulu that they have
um
and it's still up the website Ashley
Madison Ashley Madison is a website that
promotes extramarital affairs
wow dude you can download the app on
Apple
I'm shocked you can get the iPhone app
this is crazy bro that this website
exists millions of people just like you
are looking for a discreet connection so
everyday people like you okay so so
here's the deal
I mean this is crazy look at the website
when monogamy becomes monotony this is
so crazy actually I've never seen this
website this is crazy to actually look
at this
did you know infidelity is emotional
while adultery is physical cheating is a
nuanced topic and everyone has different
reasons for joining a dating site like
Ashley Madison our members are united in
a desire to seek out wow
that is just wild and then this so this
so in 200 like two
look at this the the quote I cheated on
my member experiences I cheated on my
husband to find companionship and to
feel happy and alive again I I love how
they don't quote the dudes you know
I was looking for [__] Craig
Idaho
didn't get it by the way
couldn't find really anybody you know
most of the women were fat or fake dude
so in 2002 it started they got like you
know
a few maybe a hundred thousand
uh
people on it which is a lot but then by
like 2007 they were saying that they had
like 60 million or something anyway the
dude who was the creator not the Creator
the CEO I forget his name something like
Ned meter Lander went on a bunch of talk
shows and was like yo this is what it is
and everyone hated him he was like the
most hated guy in the world whatever
and so someone hacked his [__] and
exposed everything on Ashley Madison
and expose everybody they expose
everybody on Ashley Madison and saying
how like uh
they give them a month to defunct the
website and the netherlander guy was
like no I'm not doing that [__] so they
exposed everybody
people started killing themselves
because they were exposed they were
losing jobs the fact that they were
cheating
um and our whole time I'm watching this
[__] and I'm just like man thank God I
was never on Ashley Madison dude
crazy bro
so crazy so now it's still it's still
they they got sued because they were
making fake profiles of women because
dude when you make a website like this
there's one kind of person that are on
that's on this these websites
dudes
and I know women cheat too but not like
this dude
women don't cheat women don't go looking
to cheat you know what I mean women go
like this wait a minute I I I'm in way
over my head I I shouldn't be doing this
they're fixing their [__]
I think it's out of control they'll say
it's out of control before anything even
happened
we really shouldn't be I know but and I
by mistake I I think that we held each
other's gaze too long
I know we were at separate restaurants
across the street
but we were looking through the window
and I got way ahead of myself I I I I
have they're not even with someone
already I've had I'm gonna have a family
one day with somebody if I meet them
and do dudes go to the [__]
so they they were like and then and then
they made fake profiles for women
because they needed more women they were
something like something like 65 60
million this is not but it was something
like
45 million people on it and like 44.5
million people on it were men okay so
it's like all right if 500 000 women are
on it which is by the way a lot of women
a lot of women how many of them are hot
how many
now let me be let me be generous
let me err on the side of the positive
four
you're probably if you're smart you're
probably like probably not even four
hot
women who go to a website to cheat
I mean honestly men who go to a website
to cheat
ugly pretty safe bet right no job right
so then what do you call it they got
exposed for the fake profiles and fraud
and then it's like they got sued but not
really because they're still in business
they didn't
[__] the company up all that much
now they boast 65 million members online
which I don't know how true that is but
dude hey
no [__] you're talking to someone fake
on the internet dude I don't I don't
know if you the internet's the kind of
thing when
it's the kind of thing when you like
it's the same idea as when you like
found out Kevin Spacey was gay you know
when you if you're talking to someone
fake on the Internet it's the same thing
as it's like someone says oh you're
talking to someone fake on your that
person's fake you go uh yeah maybe
oh yeah yeah
right like he's not out there just like
I put a sign up right in the front
window advertisement right in the front
window and all of a sudden success
coming out of the blue right he's in
dope [__] like seven you know what I'm
saying
but now when someone says yo he's gay
Connie you go yeah huh yeah
now that's on you
to not know that [__]
guys want it to be real so bad you know
I was at a strip club once a long long
time ago I'm talking about 20 years with
a buddy and this uh stripper was like I
want to hang out with you tonight with
me with a buddy and he was like oh okay
he was like wait for me outside and he
said okay and we're waiting outside and
I was like bro she's not coming out man
she's not she's like I know I know I'll
never forget it because he was like I
know dude that I trust me dude I know
when someone's lying and she's not lying
and she never came out of course and we
waited for way too long and [__]
drove home afterwards because dude you
got had man
you got had
so anyway there's 65 million people that
they say is on Ashley Madison
incredible but now they can't get their
security was so bad it was so easy to
hack apparently in the documentary
documentary was pretty [__] good I
had to stop watching it
uh because it triggered me so [__]
hard but um
but the uh
I am joking but I did stop watching it
because it was uh
I got really tired because I only watch
stuff later tonight
so uh anyway uh what do you call it they
[__] what was I gonna say now it now
it's got to be foolproof right there's
no way that they'll get hacked because
it's like going to remember when
Jack-in-the-Box killed all those people
because they ate a [__] Burger it's
like after that is the safest place to
eat
that's when I started getting a Jack In
The Box after they killed a few people
you gotta wait if you have a fast food
place you gotta wait till they kill some
people because of E coli and then you
can start eating because they gotta
clean their act up right
um
did you guys kill anyone made the drive
through have you guys killed anyone yet
no no all right
go to the next one you guys kill anyone
yes when
2014 uh I was like yeah I guess that's
good I'll get it number three
how many people did you got kill okay
Calvin you can have some too
um
yeah
I speaking of killing people I heard
that the FDA is investigate is maybe
going to investigate Logan Paul's Prime
energy drink and uh um
uh the other guy uh what what is it KSI
I just followed him on Instagram
I I remember uh KSI when KSI and Logan
Paul were gonna um box and they boxed
but beforehand KSI was like dude we have
to do like this press conference can you
please come out and be the surprise
guest and I was like oh yeah let me
think about it and I never got back to
him because I was like what the [__] am
I going to say you wanted me to roast
them I don't like roasting people
also I should have never [__]
remember I remember when I when I did
that thing about uh Logan Paul I was
making my [__] years ago I make a
photo of him I shouldn't have done that
dude he was going through enough pain
um
uh to be clear I love Logan Paul uh
what what the [__] is the
where'd it go okay Prime energy drink
FDA is being
because of it I didn't know this but it
has five times
caffeine as Coca-Cola right isn't that
right is that what it is
six cans of coke dude and all I say is
this to that dude honestly like being if
I'm being totally real
honestly
hell yes
me after five sips of prime hell yes yep
a hundred percent dude give me that [__]
I'll go on stage my [__] head will
pop off it'd be like that old Jim Carrey
skit when he's playing Michael Bolton
and he goes win a man and his [__]
head just explodes
for my Living Color dude awesome I want
all that caffeine
so
I love it props to them for making a
drink finally with enough caffeine
finally right I don't have to [__]
isn't uh
so here
an influencer backed energy drink that
has earned viral popularity among
children is facing scrutiny for
lawmakers although if you are [__] 12
drinking two primes you know oh that's
like 10 that's like 12 Cokes
yikes I'm sure it's got sugar in it too
um Senator Charles Schumer called on the
Food and Drug Administration is that is
he related to uh Amy Schumer I heard he
was
although that sounds like something that
somebody would say
uh see if they're related
um a beverage brand found by YouTube
Stars Logan Paul and KSI that has become
something of an obsession among
influence yeah it [__] apparently in
the UK it's Bonkers you can't even get
it
um
they're related
Amy Schumer's Dad's cousin that must be
why he saw so such a [__] cuck right
here on Sunday Charles Schumer called in
the drug food the [__] snitch ass
[__] you know
family
um
yeah so it was an immediate sensation
this is the thing dude the government
doesn't want you making a lot of [__]
money dude they want to control you this
is crazy dude God damn it I sound like a
[__] Biden's a lizard I sound like
I'm queuing on dude
what am I doing I need to stop
oh [__]
am I queuing on I'm queuing on dude [__]
that what's after q a q r I'm aranon I'm
run on
rain on
Aur Anon dude
[__] that I'm zionon Xenon all right
enough dude that joke's not funny and
I'm I'm still going dude
look at this a company it probably does
have the same amount of caffeine as
[__] Monster Energy and [__] like
that I don't know I don't know [__]
but um it's like such [__] dude you
know what they're trying to do they're
trying to [__] honestly keep a black
man down and that's terrible and I mean
KSI not Logan Paul right
that's it
it's it's a race thing finally good it's
a race thing Schumer's racist
uh
I mean these titles these [__] titles
suspect in 1982 Tylenol poisonings is
dead dude that was [__] 50 years ago
why is this a headline
it doesn't even happen to him he just
died of old age
this is such dude Larry Nasser was
stabbed in federal prison Jesus yeesh
well
two and a half red bulls to for five
stab wounds is worth two and a half red
five two and a half red bulls is one
prime
it is a lot more that's still
yeah it's a lot more that's a lot more
but whatever though dude if people know
I don't know I go back and forth on that
uh food thing it's like if you're really
eating McDonald's the thing is is so
[__] affordable is McDonald's is so
affordable it's so although it's not
that you can cook man if you cook if you
get the food and cook fine but the
problem is people need to work long
hours they're single moms they need to
pay for health care or uh I'm sorry
child care and then they gotta go home
and then I have the time to cook I want
to spend some time with their kids so
they go quickly at McDonald's and the
[__] is like four bucks for [__]
defeat a family of nine
and of course everyone knows McDonald's
is [__] but you know it's like at least
the time I am alive I'll get to hang out
with my kids wow this is actually so sad
great great Chris comedy podcast
I love the [__] dude everyone the
fact that they're trying to cancel Jonah
Hill here
because he literally the thing he's only
the only thing he's guilty of is
breaking up with his chick
this is such extreme [__] [__] [__]
Jonah Hill's ex Sarah Brady calls him
emotionally abusive because he broke up
with her dude and everyone's like [__]
him he's trying to extinguish her light
dude these texts are breakup texts
[__] this kind of [__] makes me so
happy I was canceled so I can say this
[__] and not be uh like this is [__]
horseshit
she leaked first of all [__] this for
leaking the texts
she's obviously heartbroken and whatever
but like deal with it on your own [__]
and look at this take into our Instagram
stories over the weekend Sarah who is a
semi-professional surfer sure by the way
imagine being a semi-professional surfer
either do it leisurely or be Pro
you know
it's like you didn't make it all the way
then just make it your hobby
um screenshots of alleged text exchange
between herself and Jonah the pair made
the romance public 2021 and uh the
message you shared by her showed a
contact she'd saved as Jonah asking her
to remove any photos videos of herself
surfing that showed her ass in a thong
okay from from Instagram so he said yo I
don't want you to have your ass out
and that's why I'm not so
that he said I don't want you to have
your ad basically what he says I don't
have your ass out because I can't that
that's not the kind of girl I want to be
with and then she was like
so they broke up and then she's like and
then she took the by the way two years
later right
or a year later I don't even know this
is a warning to all girls if your
partner is talking to you like this make
an Exit Plan love y'all
call me if you need your all the posts
are removed from my page she said he
said good start but you don't seem to
get it but it's not my place to teach
you I've made my boundaries clear you
refuse to let go of some of them and
you've made that clear I hope it makes
you happy
he says that one that isn't of your ass
and I think she's not a thong but okay
as far as other pictures you are in a
bathing suit surfing or not
he says I'm done there's tons I'm just
going back the past month you want to
argue and I don't you're done what does
that mean I'm just over explaining
myself so he broke up with her
here we go oh here we go this was it he
wrote plain and simple if you need
surfing with men boundary lists and
appropriate friendships with men to
model to post pictures of yourself in a
bathing suit to post sexual pictures
friendships with women who are in
unstable places and from from your wild
recent past Beyond getting a lunch or
coffee or something respectful then I'm
not the right partner for you if these
things bring your place of happiness I
support it and there will be no hard
feelings these are my boundaries from
romantic partnership my boundaries with
you based on the way so this is what he
said and then
she posted all these screenshots like
he's emotionally abusive dude he just
didn't want your [__] he didn't want
to be with somebody and I don't by the
way I don't even think what you're doing
is wrong I don't give a [__] dude if I
had a [__] girlfriend that did that
[__] do it all day long I don't care I
don't think what you're doing is wrong
but dude to try and get the mob to come
after somebody shaming them because dude
this will break up he didn't want to be
with your ass
he didn't want to be with you
and he set up a bunch of I don't want to
have somebody in my life that dude it's
like
and now because he said this everyone's
coming after him oh [__] him she he's
trying to put out her light he's trying
to control what happened to [__] he's
standing up for what the [__] he wants
dude if the rules reversed and a woman
did this everyone would be like oh dude
well you know he couldn't respect her
boundaries dude it goes both ways
he doesn't want to [__] be with her
period dude
maybe he was just literally making all
that [__] up because he didn't like the
way her breath smelled you don't know
you don't no dude emojis you clap Emoji
Don't Clap Emoji no clap Emoji dude it's
such horseshit dude I guarantee you this
motherfucker's having a day this dude
the least Ducks the guy made a [__]
documentary on Netflix about how
important therapy is you're gonna come
after this [__] he's an ally
it's so
shitty dude
it's between them two
now I'm a huge fan of Jonah Hill
I'm going to every one of his [__]
movies dude I'm going outside of his
house and just watching in his window
and every time I go eleven dollars dude
thanks for the matinee
um it's just so [__] up man every the
world is so [__] up dude
that's not emotionally abusive
it's just
a breakup who the [__] breaks up ah dude
unless you're ah very nice nice to meet
you oh very good let's go we had a Time
didn't we darling here's some parting
flowers and if you did that you'd be
like he's condescending he's sarcastic
that's emotionally abusive dude you just
broke up you know people are like oh but
we were supposed to be together forever
no [__] dude that's why you get into a
relationship
how many people get in a relationship
they go
do you go all in or you go or you're not
if you don't go all in you're a piece of
[__] they appreciate [__] the other way
so crazy dude
it's [__] so people don't know the
real story about anything obviously have
personal [__] experience with this
[__] but it's like so crazy dude
and the same people who see this and
they go oh the meat you know the media
is taking them [__] to task and they
go oh this is sucks oh that's rough and
it's like okay well then just say you
believe the media then just say you
believe the media because everybody who
does this [__] they also say oh well we
know the media lies oh yeah we don't
want to believe in the media what are we
[__] idiots and then they see this
[__] and they go oh what a [__] piece
of [__] you know them just say you
believe the media just say you believe
the media just say it just say it just
be someone who believes me that's fine
with that that's fine but don't act like
you're one of the people who are uh
enlightened who know this [__]
didn't mean to be on one but was on one
got some misconnections here
um well we have one long one actually uh
that I wanted to see to do
um
and then these desserts guys are older
right
they're now okay
um
clean but thread bear washcloth looking
for a lady
Beverly Hills adjacent
I I have a full into this is uh from
misconnections on Craigslist I have a
full intact yet somewhat threadbare
washcloth that I'm looking to trade as
far as washcloths go it's pretty it's a
pretty standard one that I bought years
ago at either Target or Bed Bath and
Beyond
it matched the towels it's a descriptive
did I mention it's blue they mentioned
that it's blue I was actually picturing
it was blue so that's that's crazy how I
am
I'm just kind of a sucker I think it's
called royal blue okay well you know do
the research and then make the post but
um I get it's getting a bit worn down I
don't want to say worn out because
there's still a possibility that there's
some good use left in it for the right
person I mean you know it just doesn't
suit my needs anymore honestly if you're
putting parentheses in a [__]
Craigslist post
well this is the kind of guy who would
do it the person that like has a
washcloth for 900 years
um
just attention to detail that said it
may be perfect for someone else maybe
you use threadbare washcloths for
certain activities or chores
like Automotive stuff or deep cleaning
I personally keep my place rather tight
this is still the post I personally keep
my place rather tidy but I don't need I
don't I don't really do much work under
the hood Beyond sometimes checking the
oil or jumping a battery
so I have this blue threadbare washcloth
that I'm looking to trade for something
here's a comprehensive list of things I
need
and then it says below jobs wow do it a
what
walk for that honestly just for that I'm
gonna suck that guy's dick bro hit me up
I said I would sleep with dudes here we
go man
Delia's a cuck
that's [__] funny dude
and then it says do not contact me with
unsolicited services or offers that's
great dude very well written very
masterfully written
that was like a [__] what's it called
an M Night Shyamalan script
oh at the end just oh at the end yeah
okay I knew it was some I knew something
was going on
um
while we're here let's just do some
deserve it scales here since we got them
uh
uh sorry
this
like coming up over Hills and stuff and
the front end gets super loose oh no on
a motorcycle
ouch
oh the guy actually said ouch
oh that sucks oh God damn he says ouch
not even R ow not even ow just ouch who
says the CH if they're actually hurt the
guy fell off a motorcycle dude why was
he doing that
I do a few speed wobbles and oh God
ah
I've gotten a few speed wobbles on this
like coming up over Hills and stuff I
mean he's going 50.
60. and your grip just like Amplified
oh there was one very quick frame where
I saw his feet were in the air so that
is terrible oh God that's terrible dude
that's low on the description because
that's I mean he did deserve it but
that's sad
I know he was talking about doing it and
still doing it and knowing it was bad
um
somebody said thank you for showing us
but you didn't have to crash your bike I
would have taken your word for it
dude this is funny then I kind of wrote
once my brother was asked to show us how
he accidentally spilled his full plate
of spaghetti when he took it slightly to
grab a fort he reloaded his play and
then said good job
holy [__] dude that's great
so demeaning to the guy in the
motorcycle just post that after it too
um
oh it's so funny
my son I put on people falling on
YouTube my son was [__] laughing bro
I loved it they don't get hurt too bad
but rude
walking up the stairs come on in if you
got some [__]
what a great shot dude
that's a [__] that's a 10 bro I mean
that's a 10. he's so drunk wow it's rare
we have a 10. deserve it
this woman is filming for some reason
get going up the thing
come on and if we got some [__]
[Laughter]
and then the door closes and she reopens
and he's on the [__] he's on his ass
all the way down a flight of stairs that
is great dude that is something that I
am absolutely texting all of my tax
groups
that is so great dude come on in we got
some buzzard
ah what a great one ten what a beautiful
10. here we go
here's another one deserved scale
hold on
oh
oh big ass wave
oh I know just what that tastes like
I mean yeah he yeah he yeah he was just
about a second too late
I mean I'd say that's a five that wasn't
too crazy but but
wow that that one I mean that one come
on
10. um all right cool uh so that's it we
got the merch the pockets stay deep
merged with the diving board on it uh we
got uh grower die merch and then my
shows are on sale oh dude uh Breya and
Irvine are gonna be on sale uh By the
time this comes out I believe I got a
few dates in Brea and a few dates in
Irvine Orange County so
um go to chrisley.com for that and if
you want to sign up for the patreon the
extended version of this show the uncut
the unedited uh go to patreon.com
christalia thank you very much guys
[Music]
more welcome